Speaker 1: . A New York City is now putting
in place the strictest vaccine mandate in
the country.
This is Bill de Blasio, New York City mayor,
on his way out.
Remember with incoming Mayor Eric Adams replacing
him soon?
Here's what's going on in New York City starting
on December 27th and maybe specifically timed
in advance of New Year's Eve, New York City's
vaccine mandate will expand to all private
sector workers.
The what counts as vaccination will change
to two doses rather than one.
Kids aged five to 11 will be subject to the
vaccination mandate and all will have to show
proof of full vaccination, meaning two doses
to do indoor dining and to go to other activities
starting December 14th, which is a week from
today.
This is all sort of happening in the context
of Omicron, even as we don't know exactly
what the outlook is.
As I just told you, it appears to be more
contagious and early data suggests it is less
severe.
Now there's a couple of questions here.
One of the big questions is OK, grades a vaccine
mandate, vaccinate or else or else what?
And it's not totally clear yet.
And the or else what some legal experts are
saying is what could determine whether this
stands up to a court challenge.
Now I'm just being upfront on the one hand
for these types of mandates, just actual straight
up mandates being legal.
Is this?
I believe it's Jacobson v. Massachusetts case
from nineteen oh three and the smallpox vaccine
that continues to be what we point to and
say these these mandates are legal.
When the idea of a federal mandate was brought
up, there were questions about, well, would
Jacobson v. Massachusetts, which was a local
mandate in the city of Cambridge?
I believe it was Cambridge.
Would that apply to a federal vaccine meant?
Well, it's not really clear.
Well, it seems that state and local vaccine
mandates are more likely to pass muster.
But then another wrinkle to this one lawyer
I spoke to this this morning mentioned is
what is the or else if it's just a fine, if
you don't get vaccinated, that's more likely
to stand up to a court challenge.
If it's something else that we don't yet know.
Maybe it won't.
I think almost certainly there is going to
be a legal challenge to this.
I have no idea what the outcome of that would
be.
One thing we know is that vaccine mandates
work now that doesn't tell us whether they
are legally OK, and that doesn't tell us whether
they are morally OK.
Those are different issues which each of us
can grapple with, and I tend to think that
they are OK.
But vaccine mandates work, and despite all
of the hyperbolic and histrionic claims, every
time such a mandate is put in place that everybody
is going to quit, 20 percent of the NYPD is
going to quit.
We end up with between half and one percent
of any particular workforce saying, that's
too much and I'm going to bail, so they do
work.
The reality is that at some point.
We don't know when.
My hope is that it's sooner, but it may be
years at some point.
COVID becomes less severe.
That's generally the evolution of these viruses.
Check out my interview again with Vincent
Racaniello from a few weeks ago.
Once that happens, it would seem logical that
the COVID vaccine would go back to being the
same sort of status as the flu vaccine, which
is some people get it and some people don't.
And it's not a big controversy in this way.
Let me know your thoughts about what New York
City is doing, and I'm less and less curious
legally.
Courts will sort that out.
I'm less curious in terms of efficacy.
We know that they work morally speaking.
Where are you on vaccine mandates like this?
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember that tomorrow, I'm sorry.
One week from today, not tomorrow.
One week from today is the the next David
Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall.
It'll be December 14th, 6:00 p.m. Eastern
Time, Eastern Time.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show does truly depend on
your support to fund the daily production
of this program, we have employees.
I try to be a good boss.
We offer benefits and health insurance contribution,
retirement account, etc.
I try to be a good boss and we try to put
out a quality product every day.
And the last half of 2021 has been really
tough in terms of memberships.
I don't often speak in terms of these frank
you.
You always have to pretend everything's always
going as well as ever.
But the last six months have really been tough
and it makes sense because a lot of elements
of the economy have been very tough.
But if you're someone who can put a few bucks
a month towards a program that you presumably
value, if you're in our audience, I would
love for you to sign up and join Packman dot
com and you can use the coupon code better.
Twenty one and I will make one other offer
to you, which is if you pay full price for
a year membership, meaning 60 bucks.
I'm glad to send you a free David Pakman show
T-shirt of your choice.
Just email info at David Pakman dot com and
let us know once you've signed up.
Remember it's got to be a full price yearly
membership.
I mean, we can't.
We can't lose money, right?
Otherwise, it's counterproductive.
But if you buy a full price yearly membership,
I will gladly send you a free T-shirt.
Just reach out when you sign up, join Packman
dot com is the place to do it.